president Trump's interim pick for
attorney general faces questions about
his qualifications and the
constitutionality of his choice
Republican Senator John Kennedy of
Louisiana said he hopes Matt Whitaker's
appointment is short-term we spoke to
the Judiciary Committee member on Friday
what is your view about the fact that he
is not a senate-confirmed person I think
he will be there for a short while I
think the president will very shortly
announce a permanent nominee the interim
I think everybody including my
Democratic friends ought to give him a
chance to find the men's room before
they try to beat him half to death it's
funny but listening do you talk about
the branches of government and the role
of the various branches I was struck by
something he said which was that the
that he thought Marbury vs. Madison was
incorrectly interpreted and that the
judiciary doesn't have a co-equal role
in the American system I don't agree
with him on that one I would advise him
to - to hit hit hit that case a second
lick because that's not quite what it
says the he also said the courts are
supposed to be the inferior branch of
the three branches of government I don't
agree with that either
do you think there should be legislation
to protect Mahler kinda links
constitutional I don't think Congress
can tell the president who he can fire
and can't fire so what is it gonna
happen with this interim AG according to
Senator Kennedy well they'll be I mean
he thinks that there will be an
appointment from the White House and
they'll do just handle that right away
so he thinks it'll be a very short term
appointment we were we were down there
talking to Senator Kennedy because he
taught a government class at McKinley
magnet school and 90 minutes with eighth
graders walking them through all the
branches of government it was a
fascinating for looking to the senator
but really a look into those really
whip-smart kids I think it's a great
idea
yeah more sure they would agree I love
his analogies though find the men's room
is it hard that's right
future no it's much harder to find a
woman's a vehicle
it's getting easier to find the women's
room well feature more of that interview
with Senator Kennedy next week
we followed him back to there it is
McKinley magnet school to watch a
special lesson on how government works
you'll be able to find it here only on
CBS this morning